[Música]
y explicar con palabras de este mundo
que partió de mí un barco llevándome
todas las cosas
en su conjunto y cada una de ellas en su
individualidad son historias
vemos historias en los noticieros en las
películas en los libros pudiéramos
considerar al derecho la obra narrativa
del estado una especie de historia el
branding basa todo su actuar a través de
historias
y no los chismes serían una construcción
interactivas de historias son tan
importantes las historias en nuestras
vidas que las hemos incorporado a las
redes sociales hasta la historia la
historia de instagram de facebook de
twitter ahora cuando nos demos cuenta
estarán en los cajeros automáticos no
podemos deshacernos de ellas tal es la
importancia que el ser humano le otorga
a la narración al arte de narrar pues
bueno entre todas las historias yo
quisiera que nos enfoquemos en una que
considero muy importante a que la
historia que habita en nuestra mente en
ese rincón indómito de nuestro ser
aquella historia con la que interioriza
interpretas tu propia existencia lo que
te dices de ti misma especialmente
cuando sientes que has traicionado la
idea que tienes o que otros tienen de ti
es un tema que me puede mucho porque yo
como migrante soy una mexicana una
yucateca viviendo en italia desde hace
varios años he tenido que reinventarme
constantemente en méxico era una abogada
muy comprometida con los derechos
humanos ejercía la docencia participar
en programas de radio tenía una vida muy
activa y al mudarme a un recóndito
pueblo del sur de italia
dejo de hacer todas esas cosas
saben lo que es un twist un giro
narrativo cuando en el relato sucede
algo puede ser un hecho o puede ser la
revelación de una información que se
mantenía oculta
y cuando esta revelación o este hecho
sucede cambia el curso en la dirección
por completo de la historia pues bueno
yo sentía que este plus twist que había
vivido
había resultado en mi contra que era
alguien más quien estaba narrando no yo
me sentía extranjera de mi propia
historia
de ser una persona muy comunicativa me
encanta hablar imagino que se nota pasó
a tener dificultades para poder
explicarme en las cosas más sencillas
porque no dominaba la lengua mucho menos
el dialecto y los modismos todo ese peso
cultural que recae sobre las palabras
además las leyes eran diferentes
entonces yo no podía ejercer el derecho
yo que enseñaba literatura mexicana al
mudarme italia yo conocía a muy pocos
autores italianos sentía que había
perdido las cosas en las que yo era
buena las cosas que me definían al punto
de exiliarme mí misma
hasta que un día cruce una frontera de
la cual no había punto de regreso
me convertí en madre de una niña hermosa
que me hizo replantear toda mi
existencia ese fue mi twist porque para
empezar
yo jamás hubiera imaginado que iba a
desear tanto ser madre
en segundo lugar nunca me hubiera
imaginado que iba a disfrutar tanto de
serlo y en tercer lugar
no esperaba que dentro de la maternidad
yo pudiera encontrar este trampolín de
vitalidad y de energía y de inspiración
que ella hubiera encontrado yo mi propia
salvación porque decidí empezar a seguir
mis sueños oa retomar mis sueños retomé
la escritura retomé la docencia no me
había atrevido a estudiar literatura que
era un sueño que yo tenía desde siempre
entonces estudiar una maestría en
literatura fui creando nuevos espacios
culturales aquellos que no existían el
lugar donde yo vivía había espacio para
ellos poco a poco fui retomando y
asentando mi propia historia mi propia
narración con todo este gran plot witt
que nos ha sucedido con la pandemia
bueno digamos que yo ya había entrenado
para muchos cambios 6 mudanzas en seis
años ahora vive en florencia
bueno cuando empecé a hablar recite un
poema de alejandra pizarnik
explicar con palabras de este mundo que
partió de mí un barco llevándome
la escritora la escritora argentina
vivió en el siglo 20 de una infancia hay
una adolescencia algo complejas
tortuosas siempre resintió la
comparación que su madre le hacía con su
hermana y el rechazo por su aspecto
físico que no comulgaba con los
estándares de belleza de la época esto
le deja era una sensación de orfandad
que se combina con una sensación de
extranjería porque su familia era una
minoría cultural eran judíos que habían
llegado a argentina de eslovaquia me
parece
era lesbiana y su familia jamás la
acepto por ello al punto de que después
de muerta mantenían ocultos los diarios
de alejandra pizarnik tuvo un final muy
trágico a la idea a la edad de 26 no de
36 años a la edad de 36 años alejandra
pizarnik se quite la vida
dejándonos eso sí con hermosísimos
versos
se entiende mejor ahora el poema de
pixar de verdad
y explicar con palabras de este mundo es
decir que lo que ella estaba viviendo lo
consideraba completamente ajeno a esta
realidad tan ajeno que no había una
manera de comunicarlo estaba sola en
ello que partió de mí un barco
llevándome chau adiós no estoy acá soy
un vacío en este mundo
que hubiera pasado
de alejandra pizarnik hubiera encontrado
los referentes adecuados que hubieran
pasado sin pisar ni hubiera leído a
pizarnik alguien como ella con quien
identificar sus sentires durante mucho
tiempo la historia y las historias de
las mujeres se han limitado a las
opiniones que tienen sobre nosotras un
montón de hombres
el sexo débil' nos llamaban por ahí un
filósofo postulaba que éramos un hombre
inacabado un filósofo insignificante se
llamaba aristóteles
y aunque las historias tuvieran o
pretendieron tener un semblante
feminista como madame bovary la tía tula
a quien diga que fortunata y jacinta
pero no me convence
estas historias serán escritas por
hombres
y se nota
eso nos llevaba a adoptar una narrativa
en un lenguaje que no es el nuestro esto
es algo que hasta la fecha lo reciente
la inteligencia artificial porque cuando
los programadores son en su mayoría
hombres estas tecnologías se comportan
con el sesgo con el que son obviamente
programadas
pudiéramos creer que hemos superado esa
época en la que nuestras historias se
contaban desde fuera pero no es así o al
menos no el todo
porque tenemos que tomar en cuenta que
prácticamente no solo el canon sino toda
nuestra civilización o casi todas se ha
construido desde la mirada de los
varones y de los colonizadores y
colonizadoras esto es algo importante
desde ahí se ha formado un arquetipo de
mujer es decir un modelo en prototipo
que las mujeres hemos de consagrar todos
nuestros esfuerzos para alcanzar para
alcanzar aquello que se espera de
nosotras de nuestro personaje
si bien ya pasaron varias décadas desde
que la pregunta era eres una jackie o
una marilyn y hoy existe una variedad de
modelos de arquetipos para elegir por
ser modelos por ser moldes no dejan de
ser jaulas jaulas que aprisionan nuestra
verdadera esencia a nuestro verdadero
ser quiénes somos realmente nuestras
historias porque somos nuestras
historias
en esta era digital
que está sumamente incrementada por los
tiempos de coronavirus vivimos casi toda
nuestra experiencia social a través de
internet
esta era digital que nos proporciona una
falsa sensación de control sobre nuestra
imagen porque vamos a elegir nuestra
mejor celtic entre millones que nos
podamos tomar y vamos a aplicarle
filtros ediciones borrar lo que está mal
lo que no nos gusta imperfecciones
mejorar la imagen colocar adornos
no nos permitimos apreciar el error los
chuecos los desalineado
en un mundo que enaltece lo lee solo ya
no lo pulido como diría el filósofo bien
surjan no queda espacio para el desgarre
para el dolor
si no me crees mira tu celular o las
televisiones de pantalla plana los
diseños sobrios lisos austeros
monocromáticos brillantes
no permitimos marcas rayas estrías
tachaduras todo lo que representa y
fealdad queremos cancelar todo lo que
representa incomodidad pero que a la vez
también representa resistencia
mujeres mezclando que no se hable
mujeres envejeciendo ahí no que las
escondan mujeres quejándose no son las
formas
400 años antes de pizarnik teresa de
ávila desde españa escribió vivos sin
vivir en mí
no está en el parecido
qué hubiera pasado si teresa de ávila
hubiera vivido en nuestros tiempos y en
vez de tinta hubiera utilizado un tuit y
hubiera escrito su emblemático verso
muero porque no muero
la gente lo leería escandalizada ay
amiga todo bien amor propio dedícate o
de plano la silencian para no escuchar
nada de esto porque no nos permitimos la
vulnerabilidad no nos concedemos mirar
hacia el abismo descubrir la oscuridad
que es indispensable para poder apreciar
la luz
esta falsa transparencia de nuestros
tiempos
lleva consigo su propia condena porque
en ella podemos ser solo lo que se nos
permite peor aún solo lo que nosotras
nos permitimos porque si algo
caracteriza a estos tiempos es que la
opresión es tal que nos hemos convertido
en sus propios verdugos repitiendo nos
tengo que ser excelente en el trabajo
excelente profesional leer muchos libros
eres una buena esposa una buena hija una
buena madre una buena novia tengo que ir
al gimnasio de llevar una dieta sana
llevar una vida ética tengo que estar al
tanto de las cosas que suenan en el
mundo en la misma dama y una larga lista
de etcéteras somos víctimas y
victimarios de una cultura de la
optimización y de la comparación pero el
mayor miedo no es compararnos con otras
personas sino que nos comparamos con la
versión ideal que tenemos de nosotras
mismas
y la vida está llena de manchas de café
en el mantel de llegar cinco minutos
tarde de unos kilitos de más o de menos
de no tener ganas
y está bien está bien
con las pandemias mundiales
sobre todo especialmente pero no solo
vivimos a través de imágenes de sombras
como la caverna de platón que no son la
realidad
son apenas reflejos
poetas filósofos y filósofas
han considerado que podemos hacer de
nuestra vida una obra de arte esto nos
compromete a una narrativa original de
autogestión que quiero decir a una
escritura y una lectura que parta de
nosotras en nosotras mismas y nada más a
partir de acciones e interpretaciones
eres tu narradora principal eres tu
personaje principal sobre todo tú
dejarías que alguien agarre tu celular y
twitter o post en instagram en facebook
en tick tock en estas cosas como si
fueras tú como poste de cosas como bajo
tu nombre verdad que no entonces por qué
dejas que otros se definan porque les
dejas a otros hablar por ti sácate los
de la cabeza y de tus libreros y de
todos los lugares donde quieras
la historia es tuya tuya
tu historia las cuentas tú con tu voz
en algún punto dije algo así de qué
la mente es el rincón indómito de
nuestro ser es decir que no lo podemos
tomar
en ti estamos llenas de influencias de
sesgos de estereotipos con los que nos
han educado o mal educado
pero podemos ir derribando estas
influencias ve abriendo espacio para sus
imperfecciones para escuchar tu propia
voz y que te quede claro una cosa no
tienes por qué hacer un libro abierto no
tienes por qué dar explicaciones a nadie
si tú no le quieres decir a nadie que
eres el jefe o neuro divergente o
víctima de algún tipo de violencia o lo
que sea puedes no hacerlo lo que sí es
muy importante es que hagas de tu mente
el primer lugar seguro
si estás viviendo una historia una vida
que no es la tuya salte de ahí
migra hacia tu propia historia y si de
repente las cosas cambian aprovecha para
un plot triste gracias
y
bien